historical para Colombia for the family
of Fabian Vargas it was the public
apology eagerly awaited for 15 years in
2008 Vargas was murdered by government
soldiers his death was later reported as
a casualty of combat now for the first
time the Colombian state is
acknowledging and taking responsibility
for the killing
I offer my apology and ask for
forgiveness on behalf of the nation to
the families and friends of Alex Fabian
Vargas Hernandez and I also honor the
memory of his father Jorge who died a
year after his son unable to overcome
grief he died without knowing the truth
about his son is
Vargas is one of thousands of young
Colombians killed by government forces
between 2002 and 2008.
a sentence by Colombia State Council
ordered the apology as part of the
compensations to the family in 2018 but
it took five years and the country's
first left his government to comply with
the order
the family of Fabian fought for almost
15 years to clear their loved one's name
and even now emotions run High fabian's
mother says is that tear down the family
his death had enormous consequences for
all of us he was everybody's favorite
uncle and brother
he taught the little ones to play
football was a father figure we never
got to live like that anymore and never
will all we are asking is for this never
to happen again
however small compared to the magnitude
of the crimes this act shows that the
Colombian status finally recognizing its
responsibilities even if many questions
remain about who ordered the killings
we need the Colombian justices to
investigate the military High command of
the time investigations can't end at the
level of the soldiers who committed the
crimes those who gave the orders or knew
what was happening and did nothing to
stop it need to be held responsible as
well
nothing will bring Fabian or the other
victims of one of Colombia's civil
conflictness highness crimes back to
life yet the truth and the assurance
that it will never happen again can
bring their families some relief
[Applause]